michigan barber carl menke has been
fighting the lockdowns in his state
since the start of the pandemic a year
ago and his battle isn't quite over yet
now he has been fined 9 000
for among other things carrying a comb
in his pocket not making it up carl and
his attorney david calman
join us right now guys good morning to
you good morning how are you
i'm doing okay carl you're a barber and
you're being fined nine
thousand dollars perhaps among other
things for having a comb in your pocket
well you know occasionally someone has a
uh
a hair ball come up and we have to use
those combs as a tongue depressor
so we have to be paralyzed at all time
okay
you're just joking uh david you're his
attorney why is the state say he owes
money for nine thousand dollars
including comb money
yeah three thousand dollars of it steve
is for these minor technicalities it's
ridiculous
60 years as a barber he's never had a
complaint and then they issue these
maximum fines
six thousand dollars of the fine is for
his protesting the governor's illegal
executive
orders our supreme court said they were
illegal and unconstitutional
he protested against them they're
fighting him six thousand dollars for
protesting
steve one of the board members on this
board
that made this decision testified
against carl at his hearing
i mean the unfairness of this is
breathtaking
and we're going to fight it we're going
to appeal to court immediately we're
going to get into a real court and we'll
see what they say about it
okay now carl you know you've won your
court cases
uh this is now just a state fining you
for a variety of reasons are you going
to pay this money
you know i'm not going to pay this money
but you know here's i want to really
thank
all the people out there that have
supported me with this thing you know
what the governor tries to do and what
governments have a tendency to do under
this administration
is to become tyrannical in a sense that
they can intimidate people
by they have on
the pockets are never ending we have
only a limited amount of funds
they know they can break us so they
intimidate the citizens
using this particular type of draconian
power
right so i thank all the people out
there that have you know supported me
financially and supported me
uh spiritually and mentally and
physically uh we have gofundmes that are
helping me and quite a bit
you know if it wasn't for those these
these governors would i'd be in jail
i would i'd be in jail right now she
put in prison she put in prison the lady
from molina over on the other side of
the state
yeah they would do the same to me well
david uh the reason he has faced
scrutiny is because when governor
whitmer
locked everything down he said after a
while you can't do this
ultimately you won those cases what
what is the moral to this story about
how they went
after your client well again steve i
think
people need to understand the virus is
real there are
issues people should use common sense
but that doesn't mean the state
can trample our civil rights trample on
the constitution
and do it in an illegal way and that's
what's been happening here in our state
and people need to wake up and stand up
and
and push back on these sorts of
activities
all right and carl uh you know you've
been through the ringer over the last
year would you do it again
i'd do it in a heartbeat you know i'm an
american
someone coined me as america's barber i
like that because i'm an american and
i'm a barber
you know and uh i can stand up against
this particular type of company
tyrande it's it's unconstitutional it's
immoral
it's draconian it i can't find enough
adjectives to describe
this administration that we have here in
michigan right now i understand
you're a great barber but a lousy doctor
do not use a comb
as a tongue depressor all right carl and
david guys thank you very much